il y a beaucoup de photos euh de
grenouilles notamment des grenouilles
très colorées super belles qu'on peut
retrouver assez souvent sur Instagram
qui vont prendre des position euh qui
nous paraissent complètement exibérante
euh par exemple qui va s'abriter sous un
champignon euh qui va se mettre à cheval
sur un autre insecte et en fait ces
images faut vraiment faire attention
parce que derrière ce que nous on voit
sur insta les photographes congèlent ces
petites grenouilles et une fois qu'elles
sont soit complètement endormies soit
même morte ils vont les ressortir des
congélateurs les positionner euh dans
dans les positions que qu'ils veulent et
ensuite pouvoir prendre des photos
justement qu'on qu'on arriverait jamais
à prendre dans la nature et ils font
pareil aussi avec les souris ou les
papillons et parfois même il passe des
fils de fer dans les membres de ces
animaux pour les mettre dans la position
désirée et ensuite pouvoir prendre leurs
photos